so for me mathematica is
a halt first of all a software with
a coherent architecture which allows
to write programs in a varied manly way
by modifying as we say the
programming paradigms thus
allowing to pass in a way  to write
a program to another that's the
first point and then
the second which seems important to me
is the
almost limitless singing of everything that
can be done with it in the field in any
case the bonus concerns this  that is to say that
of mathematics
so
therefore I am a rich tree and
mathematics teacher
in the national education
teacher in high school essentially
for almost twenty years it turns out
that almost twenty years ago I was led to
use mathematica in my
teaching  and that led
almost ten years ago, therefore,
to the installation of oued mathematica
and the possibility of being able to put
everything that was possible to put in
mathematics, therefore intended for
students on  a website so
I came one morning I was led to
use mathematica in the early
days by chance
there was
at the beginning of the 90s little software
that allowed this kind of thing
and it happened that at the  over time
over
the programs and
teaching content that could be offered
from primary classes to final classes
and even after mathematics
responded
I would say to expectations by providing
the means to be able to illustrate the
concepts that was proposed in the  is
in the programs then with
regard to web mathematics halde and
the initial idea that I had
was to propose a coherent set
of resources intended for students who
do not know the
mathematica software who do not know  not
programming or computer algebra but
to ensure that they
can use it through a
web interface as simple as possible here and
therefore the interest that I could tro  uver it
was obviously there the ease of being
able to program well define your
experience so I was therefore
led to develop a
web interface in which the entry of
mathematical expressions is done there
as simply as possible by using in
addition  the terminology that is specific to
the teaching of mathematics in
France and to ensure that
all the computing power of
mathematica via the via web mathematica
is done in a
totally transparent way for
the user for the users of the
site, therefore within the framework of
teaching
mathematics one of the many advantages that I have
found in using mathematica
and web mathematica is both to be
able to
analyze answers from
an algebraic point of view  formal view is
to be able to compare them to a
satisfactory answer knowing that in
mathematics there is not always
only one answer which is exact therefore
the analysis of the proposed answers  s by the
students the second point which seems to me
more than it seems to me very
important is
the fact of being able not only to
obtain clear results
understandable by students but also
to be able to display them in a
suitable language so the work that I  was able to
carry out with mathematica concerning
music it was a work I will
simply say of
simple research intended for
teachers and students on the
construction and history of
musical damage one of the interests of
mathematics quite rightly to be able
for example in this  part
there of both obtaining calculations
but hearing the calculations that we were playing
so finally comparing
fractions to auditory parts which
are I would say ultimately usual
for a Western ear the advantage
that the fact of using  the software
allows the calculations to lead its
calculations to
relatively complex numbers but which can be
translated into are
simply and f  Play area in
the interface of the Mathematica software